let's get into this first story wow Bay
Area NBC station is running report
questioning the circumstances of Paul
Pelosi's Hammer attack which include the
same details as Today's Show segment
retracted for inaccuracies and left star
reporter Miguel Alma almaguer as I
pronounce it suspended
this is particularly interesting
they say NBC News under mounting
pressure to explain its actions after
suspending star reporter Miguel
alamoguer over one of his Today Show
segments on the Paul Pelosi Hammer
attack
it took the action despite a second
report on the company owned and operated
NBC bay area station that repeats many
of the same points in armager's report
they're going to mention that NBC
removed the footage from its website
hours after anger November 4th now we do
have another report from from uh Fox
News and this is what they mentioned
that's very very uh interesting I want
to read this one
NBC News National con correspondent
reported on November 4th for today's for
uh The Today Show that police didn't
know they were responding to the Pelosi
residents Pelosi opened the door for
police but didn't attempt to escape or
declare an emergency and even walked
away from law enforcement and toured his
eventual attacker they go into mention
last Friday exactly one week after all
McGuire's report was mysteriously
retracted with little public detail NBC
San Francisco local affiliate which is
branded as NBC bay area aired an
explosive Report with highly similar
details indicating Pelosi opened the
door for police and didn't immediately
attempt to escape
so the initial story someone broke into
pulp into the Pelosi residence screamed
where's Nancy in his underwear with zip
ties and struck Paul on the head now
that then turned into he okay he was
actually clothed
okay a third man opened the door but we
don't know what it was they changed the
story again and now the Today Show comes
out and says Paul Pelosi opens the door
doesn't try to escape walks back to the
guy who says there's nothing going on
and then who strikes him
and now the story is being confirmed
after the uh or again I should say after
the Today Show retracted uh not even
formally retracted just deleted the
video
I have to wonder
what really happened of course the
theory from the right is that it was a
late night either drug deal or love romp
gone wrong and the police responded and
you know lover's quarrel of some sort I
think drug deal makes more sense which
is why they're they're you know looked
3am Paul Pelosi is like send in the
crazy weirdo guy who's got the drugs
fight breaks out over cash or something
like that who knows or
maybe the police didn't know they were
responding to Paul Pelosi's house they
opened the door and they attacked Paul
Pelosi because he was in his underwear
and they assumed it must be a crazy guy
or something maybe the cops are the ones
who hit him and then they're trying to
cover up their story I I feel like if
the cops hit him we would be seeing like
uh defund the police part two right
nobody knows what happened it sounds
like two drunk dudes at a bar like just
you know people can get belligerent late
at night when they're both really
hammered and they don't even know what
they're talking about that one guy just
gets angry and then they're like and
then they just start to bump into each
other like that's what it sounds like
well David and Paul were doing well
personally I'm just sick of the
speculating I don't want to speculate
anymore release the body cam footage
release the surveillance footage then we
could actually know what happened here
otherwise you don't give the government
any benefit of the doubt we're talking
about career criminals who parade
themselves around like some high-level
politicians and officials they're not
these people are up to some really nasty
stuff we're talking about so much
corruption within the uh Losi family
we're talking about so much money that
they earned off of America's back
they're probably you know when it comes
to government officials and people
connected to them we should always think
the worst possible scenario always go
with that until we actually have some
actual evidence they were doing
unspeakable things to small babies they
were sacrificing children let's let's
just go with that if we're going to be
speculating what happened here let's
think of the worst thing because we
shouldn't be giving government any kind
of credence any kind of leeway here and
with this story being so crazy insane
they were doing god-awful things to
small babies that's it I just assume the
worst I guess yeah absolutely and you
should what government because what
government does is probably usually a
lot worse than what we actually know
actually really happened so Paul's not
government he's only government adjacent
government adjacent well that's just as
bad that's just as bad how did he make
all of his money yeah because of his
connections to to govern obviously
pretty clear allegedly it's not even
it's not even alleged they make better
calls on the stock market than Warren
Buffett okay you don't get that lucky
it's impossible to be that lucky like
the Pelosi's have been so come on we
know what it is maybe this guy this the
pop guy was his inside source on Wall
Street and that's how he was making his
money and he was telling him to invest
in FTX and Paul was like no you screwed
me yeah that's the problem is that we're
able to speculate on this story we're
able to sit here and try to figure out
what happened and how did everybody get
in their underwear and why weren't the
cops there and the third in line to the
presidency there's there's somebody
getting their underwear yeah where did
the hammer come from and I can't believe
that nobody is selling hammers online
like the Paul Pelosi Hammer uh
right yeah and help you win a chess
match perhaps
correctly it's some Insider humor here
yeah
uh but I but that's the thing all of
this speculation could be over with if
if the government released the body Cam
and released the actual information that
is out there and give us the clear story
and we are not getting the clear story
because what this is Paul once again is
this an excuse for Nancy to retire and
try and score points like
I don't understand it seems to me like
happened that they're trying to cover it
up it really seems to me like it was
something that went wrong like you said
maybe it was a bad drug deal or they
they were getting weird together who
knows and then and then the cleanup team
came in they were just like all right
now what are we gonna do we gotta we
gotta make this look like something and
then the the script writers came in and
and said all right well let's make it
like this because think about how much
power is being wielded by these people
and many times Hollywood does work with
the Pentagon when it comes to scripting
narratives we have seen time and time
again something happens in Iraq and
they're like okay what can we say
actually happened what really happened
those are two completely different
things how can we use this event to and
change it for the best PR purposes we
saw that with Jessica Lynch we saw that
with Mainline Hollywood directors and
producers getting involved and saying
you know what this story of of the
Iraqis taking her to a hospital and
trying to help her does it really fit
our narrative let's send in the tanks
and let's say that they were holding her
hostage again they made so much things
up when it came to to war they make so
much things up when it comes to just our
everyday life everything from them
should be seen as fake nothing should be
believed by government or the
authorities until we actually have some
real life evidence that we can back up
their statements on because they are
pathological Liars satanic individuals
some of them that do awful things that
we can't even imagine how terrible they
are I'm okay you know I'm sitting here
and I see this story and it's a crazy
story
and I'm trying to figure out why
whatever it is they're doing matters so
much they don't want anyone to know
about it you're like like they suspended
a star reporter from The Today Show for
reporting what now sounds to be fact
what is so important about this moment
that this incident that they don't want
us to know about it that's this is the
crazy thing because I kind of look at
this and I'm like
whatever Paul Pelosi is doing I don't
care about right yeah but to go to this
degree
it sounds like something they were doing
must have mattered like politically or
something I think I think it's it's an
effort to to fend off what these who
these people really are the depravity
they just don't want their true colors
to to show even though we all know it
obviously this man
abuses some sort of substances or
something going on these people are not
on the up and up at least booze yeah
from what we know about publicly on the
record we got busted driving drunk like
within six months ago or something and
that's a problem if someone especially
in their 80s is driving home drunk
enough to get him I mean not even drunk
enough just drunk in general I've driven
drunk a couple times in my life it was
probably some of the worst I was like
near suicidal at that period of my life
too like step on the gas and just wait
for it to happen kind of suicidal and
that is a bad State of Mind to drive
drunk if someone's like if you don't
have that kind of self-control where you
can be like I actually have to drive I'm
gonna put it down that's indicates a big
problem psychologically so I imagine the
guys got maybe obvious look the midterms
this this happens right before the
midterms yeah they pull the story
after the midterms story pops back up on
an NBC affiliate it could just really be
it makes the Pelosi's look freaky and
weird and it was bad for Democrats
Republicans were running the story that
there was a gay love romp or something
and they wanted to shut it down so NBC
colluding you know or or seeking to help
maybe not colluding Democrats pulls the
story until after the midterms that
could be it it could really be as simple
as Paul Pelosi is a weirdo does freaking
things in the middle of night yeah I
think that's for sure I mean not for
sure but I think that's the case but the
connection to January 6 see how it's
it's connected to January 6th he walked
in there and and was saying where's
where's Nancy where's Nancy oh well of
course he was saying that that's another
Point that's all the that's all those
people are going to hear that's all the
the libs are gonna hear like oh but so
the question is did they twist an
existing story to make it sound like
Insurrection sure or did they fabricate
a story to try and win points before an
election I think it's exactly what what
I said before something happened
the truth happened that was something
that has to do with depravity nobody
broke into that house nobody just broke
into that house started walking around
with a hammers held up in the bathroom
that's craziness it sounds you know it
keeps changing so at this point I'm not
inclined to believe what their version
is yeah and the fact that Paul Pelosi
was not threatened when the cops answer
the door and that's the new detail now
being confirmed you know clearly the
news is again knew this guy there's got
to be cameras in that house right if
that dude was running around his
underwear going where's Nancy where's
Nancy we would see it over and over and
over that's true that for the special
propaganda purposes they would of course
weaponize that footage and have it
everywhere so we couldn't ignore it we
always have to see it everywhere and we
saw the corporate media after this being
like it's the conspiracy theorist that
are the problem here they're the ones
that are crazy they're the ones that we
have to stop they're the ones that we
have to go over we have to make sure
that people can't be able to speak to
each other and now they're punishing
journalists like this Miguel reporter by
the way this reporter uh Miguel ala
margar hasn't tweeted since November 4th
he's the one that got suspended for
originally reporting the story which we
talked about on the show that was
specifically based on police sources
what's happening to him I want to hear
from this guy Miguel if you're out there
what's going on here because this is
absolutely crazy what kind of story
you're involved I'll tell you about
conspiracy theories there's there's a
tweet I can't remember who I saw this as
a verified Twitter account saying that
uh Putin is pushing an insane conspiracy
theory that the missile that hit Poland
was Ukrainian we can't allow Russian
disinformation blah blah blah sure
enough turns out even the West is now
saying exactly that so we'll definitely
get into the Ukraine stuff in a minute
but I just want to point that out when
they come out and they're like it's a
conspiracy theory don't believe it
typically that means you know I better
look into that because uh you can't
believe these people thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time